hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
when I was through servers and this is
Tamra just saw with Taylor as well intro
pending he just runs out La Llorona I
was like lalala Nona well it was I've
been singing my Sharona and I think
that's got me messed up la Llorona
yeah no yo Rona yo this is the qu else
took three years of Spanish in high
school
nothing ya see every time or work
I should have failed my second year of
Spanish but that was the year I got hit
by a car and so all my teachers were
like you know what you're good we're
probably gonna spoil a few things in
this sorry guys it's la Llorona and we
saw it 11:30 a.m. so what are you swings
in
Velma bangs on for this is really
backfiring on me quite honest with you
so we're just gonna tuck them behind the
ears and pretend they're not there
la Llorona it's really there's little
things came out this week as well but
this was the one that I was more
interested in and so I went in excited
because I really loved horror and I
really loved the contouring series which
you've not seen any yet no I thought
this was a foreign film when you've told
me what we were seeing and then Velma
showed up oh it sure is not I love the
contouring series I love horror and this
has gotten such terrible reviews I read
a few and I looked on Rotten Tomatoes
and people were not having this this
movie no no I gotta say not as bad as
people are saying guys most those I
thought it was gonna be I didn't even
read reviews I was like it's probably
gonna be at the generics
movie but it was fine it was good you
got to go in being okay with jump scares
yeah sure sure it was a lot of jump
scares
it was almost strictly jump scaly jump
scares for the horror yeah for sure I
really enjoy jump scares if they're done
right I think that they relied way too
heavily on them but I still enjoyed them
they were just it got the scare across
because you expect the jump scare at
this point yeah but I'm still gonna do
the jump scare so they can't just do it
so now they're starting to like tease
you with it yeah
so the like it's gonna be a jump scare
and they're like panning slowly but then
nothing happens and then it happens
right after that or some shit yeah yeah
it's all delaying the timing of the jump
scares a shit like it's cuz that's yeah
I wish I'd have liked that I like the
jump scare a format I know a lot of
people don't and I respect that this
script for this was ridiculous
yeah really poor writing in in this
whole whole endeavor the acting almost
almost made up for it I think that was
good
maybe outside of the special priest guy
wait which priest the second okay yeah
we're kind of weird
well the priests like yeah the second
one literally sounded the same tone
every for all of it yeah of the only
comedy and community Cline's and he's
hired movie and I'm really glad I didn't
try to like shoehorn in comedy into this
because it did not call for it but this
guy had some like tough-guy Kombi Lions
like two or three and it just had no
difference in his tone which I don't
know it could have maybe worked for
someone else but it didn't really work
here I think that I don't know her name
but Velma she ruled man did she oh in
the movie and Anna we're watching yeah I
noticed that later I was like always
scooby-doo of course yeah overall the
like folktale this folktale
fuck - right I think that all really was
creepy and like I think they did a good
job showcasing it because it's an actual
like legend that she drowned her kids in
a fit of rage because her husband
cheated on her and then it would
immediately just shrouded in guilt she
killed herself doomed to forever walk
the earth and try to replace her
children so she takes other kids and
tries to drown them and sure that's
effective we get a lot of up-close looks
at her and I definitely seen worse I
think that it was effective
I like this she had like a moment of
softness - like a grand return - like
some kind of plot there's a word for it
probably whatever it was the moment of
like ha there's like humanity it's like
the last bit of that in there yeah yeah
it's like this is what cost brings her
back yeah it was it was really nice I
will say this I know this was set I
think it felt 70s 70s I don't know
because those TV shows they're watching
all were real dated it was like Leave It
to Beaver leave it to Justin Bieber well
the TV and the cars were all super dated
I think it was 70s it's what I want to
say I didn't feel it didn't feel modern
yeah
are there no light bulbs in the 70s yeah
there's like one light bulb in that one
closet it was so insanely dark the
entire movie was so dark hard to see oh
yeah
so to see what's going on that wasn't so
much scary as it was just like
disorienting I like hard to follow that
was a bummer also I kind of wish it was
set in Mexico I think it would have been
like kind of cooler and more stylized it
was a really pretty set and they did a
good job with it but it was just kind of
something like okay well we've seen this
a million times
and like the the folklore is from the
Mexico it would be cool to be like
stylizing that it wasn't like bad not
it's a culture yeah it's been really
cool the the biggest plot device that
they use that they shouldn't have used
was not miscommunication endless
miscommunication happens for sure that's
fine it's nothing to you know call him
about but it just seemed like the
characters in this movie were really
stupid purpose they didn't communicate
so much they went out of their way to
not communicate like she the daughter
has this crazy burn on her arm from La
Llorona and the moms like what is that
just like I fell and the moms like oh
okay and just like it's like well weird
and some exact same marks are on the
sons arm as well like what happens oh
nothing oh yeah yeah better not do
anything about this investigate further
and like you can tell the actors were so
stunted by that maybe they tried their
best to act their way and make it work
right lines they were given I just have
to drop this now I guess I have to yeah
yeah okay they clearly in other aspects
of their life weren't that stupid and so
it just feels really odd oh yeah which
like they're picking and choosing when
they're paying attention yeah and I
don't know about you or I don't know
about other family dynamics I would say
that you know we didn't have too much
communication but I think if I would
have seen a woman in a wedding dress who
burned my arm I think I would have said
something yeah especially if someone
like like what else am I gonna say about
the burns on my I'm like yeah I do yeah
I fell but cuz like also they didn't
portray the families having poor
communication issues so if they would
have done that it would have made sense
for a bit in the movie it just kind of
felt like it was like it should get
every single one of the the three family
members it's the mom and the two kids to
get all of their kind of time with La
Llorona it was like a scene building up
style
building up to jump-scare and then okay
well she's seen it she got the burnt
building seen jump-scare burn you've got
the very pool building seems obscure you
guys right so then they all collect and
took like a half hour of our time yeah
it just kind of felt like it was weird
dead space it's like very repetitious
and not very exciting
cuz the beginning I think until that
started until la Llorona was upon the
family the lead family I think up until
that it was really interesting and was
exciting enough to where I was like I
was in it restarted laugh at you I lost
it when the bitch went for her toy over
the seeds are you kidding are you
kidding it was dumb as hell yeah do
anything to not break this line of seen
[Music]
like oh you shouldn't imagine like you
deserve this girl that's karma yes
Darwin is completely but I think there
is a twist oh yeah there was a kind of
twisty guys expect that that was really
cool I really enjoyed that I think the
ending bit with the climax was exciting
it was good she is an interesting
journey she really does cuz she like
gets out and she comes back she's going
to jail now well yeah she just got out
of jail then she's like you but what I
could do to get back in hey how do I get
back to this woman who's only done me
good well until she suck wow there's a
lot of sticking La Llorona on people
there were a lot of good aspects to it
and I think it's a lot better than
people are saying but also you know the
scripts good hasn't really been helped
no I will say the the first priest who's
still with the church he's explaining
what smudging is which is when you you
burn what is it
but you burn it and then you like sage I
think it's age no I don't know it's much
plan but you burn it and it's called
smudging and he's like it's a ritual
called smudging and he said in such a
weird way and I've never worn this shirt
but very like serious manner you can't
say silly words seriously yeah yeah how
many hair flips would you give it a ten
six and a half seven maybe seven seven
hair flips I think I would give this a
yeah I would say like a six I would give
this but I don't know I still really
enjoyed it seven hair flips yeah yeah do
you want to see what this looks like off
of my head for detaining hair flips
they're fake
bangs see you next week with Infinity
Ward is that next week yeah what I know
no way bye bye Mike
are you scared of La Llorona are you
scared of him bud let me just
[Music]